I walk into the apartment I open the
door and immediately a smell hits you
now I can't really describe the smell
but it's very unpleasant so now I begin
to just you know do your general you
know just looking around and all of a
sudden I'm like like the wall is moving
so hundreds and hundreds of roaches on
this guy's wall that's just when you
walk in his mattress was completely
infested with roaches you could barely
see that the mattress the color of the
mattress I'll put it that way it looked
brown
my name is Larry Bernhardt my work for a
top-notch pest control I've been an
exterminator for about 13 years most
pests will reproduce according to food
and unfortunately New York is severely
overpopulated so there's a abundance of
food and shelter for them to just keep
reproducing you know ton of rats rodents
brooches you name it it's it's pretty
much in New York a few places I would
never want to live it's pretty much next
to old multi-unit buildings there so
like your pre-war buildings that's
basically any building that was like
built before World War 2 in New York
City there's a bunch of holes in the
buildings they're very they're not up to
date regulation wise old piping stuff
like that will always cause you know
pest problems a bunch of places for the
rodents and pests to hide and yes next
to a park because you don't know what's
going on inside of the park with all the
rodents rats tend to borrow and if
there's a bunch of ground that they
could burrow into they're gonna tend to
nest there once they start looking for
food if there's not food ready for them
they're gonna make their way into
buildings especially in the winter
they're looking for warmth if your
building is the closest to the park
you're gonna be the first place that
they go so the worst floor to live on
would actually be the ground level or
first floor pest generally start to go
from ground up especially rodents so
you'll get your rat issues and your
mouse issues from the ground up the pest
problem is terrible in their restaurants
it really has to do with the garbage
them disposing of it in the proper ways
and also in like a timely matter you
know a lot of these restaurants though
they'll just have like a dumpster out in
the back and they're just putting the
garbage right there what happens is
after
nighttime the rats are just going to eat
so as they eat they'll reproduce more
and also with these takeout restaurants
if they are having a pest problem and
one actually has a roach egg in it and
now you're putting it in their cabinet
yes you now have an infestation of
roaches I think most New Yorkers don't
know that a roach egg will typically
have 30 to 40 babies in it
so you know generally somebody sees one
roach they kill it and they kind of move
on with life they don't realize that the
first thing you should be doing is
calling a professional or at least you
know trying to take care of it on your
own that there's probably thirty more
that you're just not seeing the most
important things would actually be
taking the trash out every night
then making sure there's no dirty dishes
in the sink also no clutter clutter is
the worst because once something gets in
you're not gonna be able to find it due
to all the clutter and the messy
conditions you know we're never gonna be
ahead of it until people start taking
you know sanitary you know matters very
seriously I make my way into the bedroom
his mattress was completely infested
with roaches I've never seen that in all
the years I've been doing pest control
just I mean you could barely see it at
the mattress the color of the mattress
I'll put it that way it looked brown